we got big news my friends big news here
Shaggy's black Shaggy from Scooby-Doo is
now officially black and so is Velma oh
wait that's the wrong story there we go
that's that's a bad one about my uh
here's Mama Velma I think I don't know
if she's black maybe she's like Indian
like Mindy Kaling oh yeah but uh what
the most you know I'm really offended by
we have this uh discussing film it's
like a first look at Shaggy Daphne and
Fred voiced by Sam Richardson constant
woo and Glenn Howerton in HBO Max's
adult animated Velma series I just want
to point to point out the most offensive
thing here is they change Shaggy he's
not it's it nor canceled he's fired
Norville he's fired Shaggy can't get a
job that's not [ __ ] it's supposed to be
Shaggy but he's replacing Shack okay so
so fact check for all the Nerds they did
I think it was in A Pup Named Scooby-Doo
as a show they established that Shaggy's
real name was Norville that's why
they're saying Norville here but why and
they made Shaggy black okay look I I
don't honestly don't care but I have a
point to be made if they were going to
choose any character to be black I find
it funny that they chose the stoner
Munchies guy who is considered a coward
and I that to me is like why not Fred
that Fred is like the the strong leader
why would they I think it's racist the
progressives always end up being racist
in the end it's yeah no I I honestly I
just think it's really dumb what's on
his head it's his
hairy did not have that kind of hair
it's not Shaggy I don't yeah no longer
couldn't they have given him just like
hair like Shaggy I guess why did they
make I don't I don't understand they
gave the Asian the red hair
it's just it's just look guys made Fred
look like an idiot it's not Scooby-Doo
it's going to be the idiot I think they
even made Velma fat like not not like
fat fat but you know they made her like
chubby with a little bit of Koopa yeah a
little little fupa and chubby and just
real cringe and the trailer for this is
her basically saying that uh you can
never change she's doing a joke where
she's like you can never change things
and uh it's like everything always has
to stay the same and then she says
something like well at least the
character's still white and then it
reveals that Velma is now black or
whatever this is cultural stagnation
this is this is the death of art and
culture they can't make up new ideas
they've got no new ideas left yo it's
been 50 years Scooby it's come on yeah
and The Simpsons did you guys see The
Simpsons where Abe is gay
it's like it's like he's bi-curious or
whatever and I don't know and then
there's another Simpsons episode where
Bart gets mad that they gender swap
Itchy and Scratchy and so then feminists
like make fun of him or something like I
don't this is
guys so why do you think they're doing
this why why do you think that this is I
mean they're doing this with everything
every day no I think I think there's
some 80 year old white executive who
typed in you know Scooby-Doo into an AI
script writer and then it just spat out
some garbage and they went run with it
and that's it it's it's a kind of a
marketing Ploy too like I mean No One's
Gonna no one cares about a new
Scooby-Doo show I mean who but look at
us we're talking about it now this is
crazy it's because people are permanent
children yeah like dude I watched
Scooby-Doo when I was at really little
and it was okay and then when I go got
older I was like this is really dumb and
then I liked things like X-Men you know
when I was real Littles like Power
Rangers was fun but then after like the
first season or whatever I was like I
outgrew it and I was like eight and I'm
like I'm too cool for Power Rangers
Scooby-Doo was just not it it was the
same story every single time we get it
some dude's trying to lower property
values so he pretends to be Frankenstein
them making a new show that's aimed at
adults using these characters and then
race swapping them is just like we are
desperate we don't know what we're doing
we're gonna try and do Ghostbusters 2016
all over again is Scooby in this show
they don't even show Scooby there's no
Scooby Scooby is now a cat he's gonna be
a furry is going to be a furry I'm
calling it right now they made Daphne
Asian
okay a red-headed Asian right-headed
Asian I don't see many redheads no man
it's an alternate universe this is the
most disappointing to me because he's
supposed to be a strong leader
he was supposed to be a football star
right I don't know he's like six three
and muscular yes but now he's like super
skinny super soy
yeah yeah confused he's he's usually on
his face holding Shaggy back from the
brink that's like his main function it's
like hey everybody remember we have a
mission I I think
you made him Unstoppable I love the
Super Saiyan Shaggy memes though that
really is funny so have you guys seen
that video game multiverses
it got a lot of attention it's like
Warner Brothers Smash Brothers yeah they
got a lot of attention because velma's
super super move is to call the cops on
you but I I will admit when I was
watching the trailer for the game I'm
like oh so Warner Brothers is putting
all their characters to a fighting game
I'm like this sounds dumb and it's like
Batman was there and then also Shaggy
shows up and I think it's funny I'm like
ah Shaggy fighting and then someone like
knocks a sandwich out of his hand and
then he goes Super Saiyan and I started
busting out laughing I'm like okay
that's that that's good I approve it is
funny Shaggy going Super Saiyan so so
you know but uh but this kind of takes
away from that because I don't know who
this guy Norville guy is and I don't
know why they're taken away from
Shaggy's an iconic character he's like
the Scooby-Doo character and there's a
show called like Orville that that's
Seth MacFarlane show it's called Orville
and now they just call it Norville like
yeah Fred Fred's also demasculated he's
going to be a low IQ idiot who's going
to be making a bunch of mistakes he's
going to be the dope and he's going to
be the loser just like every guy who
looks like him is portraying the
television how amazing would it be if
Fred is no longer the leader Norville is
and every time something bad happens
Fred's like I'm sorry guys that was my
fault or it's like he jumps into
Scooby's arms he constantly does things
where he has to check his own privilege
yeah he'll be like let's see who's
really under that mask and they'll be
like don't pull off that mask it's a
cultural symbol geez Fred colonize her
much he goes I'm so sorry guys I'm so
sorry I'm wondering now sorry guys if
Scooby-Doo is like a stoner show back in
the day because Scooby and Shaggy were
high as hell most of the show like [ __ ]
he's talking to a dog
I never understand as a kid and then I
remember what like when I finally got
old enough and I was like like you know
and I was told you realize the whole gag
is that they're stoned out of their mind
yeah Scooby Snacks are Edibles for sure
Edibles yeah no I think he's just eating
I think he's eating dog food that's what
we that's what we got the money
Scooby Snacks dude they make scooby go
yeah they make they make him get like
crazy powerful the Scooby Snacks would
make him get like high you know they'd
make them kind of super crazy definitely
drugs this meme crosses the line you've
made him Unstoppable
biggest buff of all time if they can
overcome the poor theme here and the
writing is actually decent it looks like
they've got I mean Mindy kaling's I
think she's a fantastic actor so maybe
she can pull like this this was a little
the writing was kind of bad we watched
this trailer
and she's kind of phoning in the
dialogue wait hold on hold on guys she's
talking like this wait wait hold on hold
on she's dead watch there's a guy he's
got a knife she screams and then maybe
she kills
what does it say what is scoob
it says Dinkley is crossed that it says
what is scoob oh it's like is there it's
it's the show is called Velma so maybe
there's no Scooby in it like they're
looking for Scoops maybe they haven't
found Scooby yet and he's this is the
prequel he's missing yeah you know what
they should do these characters all get
killed then the real ones find their
clothes they need to make into the
Shaggy verse and it's like all the
different shaggies from different
realities team up yeah the case of the
lawful ideas please
have you guys seen the night violent
Night trailer oh it's Santa yeah oh I've
seen that one that looks pretty
interesting it's it's yeah you're right
it's like literal Die Hard with Santa I
think it looks like the best movie of
Our Generation and I'm proposing that we
do a company-wide outing at three on the
Thursday preview to go watch it so it's
uh who's at David Harbor and he's Santa
and it's just masterfully done at least
the trailer John leguizamo's in it yeah
and uh you know these their politics are
no good but their movie it looks really
great they disappointingly made Santa
white though so that's oh no I was kind
of into it until he punched into the
Santa sack in a in like a present shot
out at him no no no no he has a knife
and he stabs and it goes into the sack
and then he pulls out oh it's got his
present on the night that's cool so
basically like Santa's doing his rounds
and he's like half glazed over just like
whatever and then he stumbles upon an
active Heist on Christmas and then he's
like I don't want any trouble and then
he basically uses his Santa powers to
take on a bunch of terrorists in a big
house and I just it just looks hilarious
like the puns he's like it's time for a
season's beating
it's horrible I know so good and then he
shoved the grenade where the sun doesn't
shine did you see that one yeah and he
runs away he's like wait I gotta see
this one I'm excited for that this could
be a problem though because he's a son I
mean Santa's kind of essentially a god
like how are they gonna give him an
enemy that's gonna put him in any real
danger does is there is there like an
anti-santa out there it's like in the
trailer it doesn't teleporting he can
teleport if there's a chimney nearby or
something yeah like how are they going
to make him uh like a you know I don't
know I mean I I I just think it's going
to be funny now look look it is it is
hard to come up with new ideas because
Futurama did the robo Santa trying to
kill everybody which is not the same
thing and there's another movie I forget
what it's called it's from like the 70s
or whatever where there's a guy just
like Santa going around killing people
but this is literally Santa Claus
himself inadvertently stumbling upon a
die-hard style kidnapping Heist because
this Rich family's got a vault full of
money or whatever I think it looks
hilarious so I'm into it you know
remember what was that movie Jack Frost
the snowman that was killing him
everybody yeah yeah I never saw that
they're doing that with Winnie the Pooh
too right like are they making a oh yeah
a lot of honey
it's got a lot of potential so it is all
derivative pretty soon we're gonna have
like a Peppa Pig or a Bluey that goes
around murdering people Peppa Pig's
Revenge
yeah I think when I write music I
basically take pieces from a bunch of
different songs I've heard in the past
and then put them all together into a
new song where you don't know that those
pieces like where they're from so it's
I'm definitely we're standing on the
shoulders of giants that's it's all
mashups yeah everything we do is a
language even is a mashup of what came
before but you got to be so intricate
with it that people don't know you're
using past material right like I came up
with a show idea called doobie moo and
it's about a gang of young people that
fight crime with a pet alligator with a
pet cow named doobie oh it's a cow it's
a cow now and uh it's a it's a cow
it's an original idea great completely
original I love it and the uh the main
characters are um red yes and um
braffney they eat mushroom snacksville
and and Velma the mushrooms that grow on
doobies too and baggies
special snacks man it really is crazy
how they just like rehash old things
non-stop over and over and over again
like we're on Fast and the Furious 10.
you know they've got to use new tech new
technology I think if you want to make
new art you've got to integrate like
modern tech did you notice when the cell
phones appeared it took them like six
years before they started making cell
phones and movies because it was so cool
to have a hero that didn't have access
to the outside world couldn't resolve as
Eden Noah was going on that's the big
part of movies is you don't know so as
soon as cell phones are invented it like
erases the drama of so many movies not
not only that but you'll notice in
modern movies they'll have the cell
phone to their ear and then someone will
say something like I am coming for your
family and then you hear a click in it
and I'm like that doesn't happen on the
cell phones yeah yeah that was like and
the crazy thing is do young people even
understand that there was a a meme that
is probably not real but it's funny
where some guy was holding up a floppy
disk and he was like kid in my school
just said why did you 3D print the save
icon
I saw that yeah I have no idea well I
don't know that's real but you know yeah
they have no idea it's like they've not
used these things what a weird
turn of events for our world what the
internet has done you know what I mean
we're very fortunate to have kind of
seen both sides of it we grew up kind of
before the internet we got to see it
come and into being and now our kids
just don't they don't know a world
without it what's that going to be like
you know I don't know I mean instant
gratification all the time my uh like my
entire life we've had TV is is
ubiquitous my parents were saying that
it was like when they were younger they
didn't have TVs in their Apartments
because they were expensive and they
didn't care that much you know now it's
like flat screen TVs are in every room
because they're Dirt Cheap maybe that's
because they want to spy on us though
for sure it's manipulation like the
power and control of a government or
pipe people have over people with the TV
if you can get it I don't know but
wasn't there a story that like TVs have
microphones and cameras spying on you uh
yeah that's I think we went on a search
for for ones that didn't
um and we were going around the specific
stores and there was like one left I was
able to finally grab it and okay by
myself I have no camera no microphone
have you seen that that cost chart
there's a there's a chart going around
the internet that tracks the cost of
everything going back to the 50s and and
how prices have rised for food Health
Care cars houses literally everything
like 100 things on this chart the only
thing that has gone down is TVs yeah
it's like just a bunch of stuff going up
and then you have TVs it's the only
thing that is decreased well they also
track what you watch they also have a
lot of data on you your personal
information on there so you know that
this is why a lot of the TVs are so
cheap is because they collect a lot of
data on you and then they sell that data
yeah geez if you get people to watch the
news MSNBC you have control their minds
like do you find at Babylon B that you
guys create new do you feel like you're
creating new Concepts on here because a
lot of it's parity which is like using
an idea and then twisting it hold on let
me just interject you're wrong Ian it's
not parody it's it's prophesizing for us
can you tell us all the jokes that went
too far that you guys never published oh
my God but maybe we could do this
yeah like what's the difference between
parody and satire
um
I mean parody I feel like kind of
um is kind of aping off and off an
existing thing you know you have a you
know you you have a movie The Godfather
and then you have you know Mafia Mel
Brooks Mafia that there's a kind of a
parody of that
um satire is exaggerating reality
um you know I think a lot of what makes
uh our Pro our satire seem prophetic
sometimes is I think it's just the fact
that it's there's nothing complicated
about it so we I think we know the left
better than they know themselves a lot
of times if you if you know someone's
world view
um and then you also combine that with a
knowledge of human nature you know if
you have a solid truthful worldview it's
it's not hard to predict what people are
going to do what people are going to say
that and the Babylon bee has a vat full
of a fluid with three precogs floating
in it and then wooden balls carve out
you know the future and then they say
hey that's funny let's write that up
it's actually a seeing Stone but yeah
Babylon Beast Staffing on robes and they
all stand in a big circle holding hands
and then the crystal lights up and they
can see the feature that's right yeah
yeah and the future is funny it's very
fun it's hard though I mean yeah we get
a lot of I mean feedback all the time
um please stop please stop because
you're giving them ideas sometimes I
feel like we're giving them I mean did
you see the one recently
um we did a and it was just a throwaway
joke I mean it's we call it the one joke
of the Babylon B it's like it identifies
as joke you know blank identifies as
blank so he can blank
um and it was a it was a like Eminem's
uh introduces new uh purple trans Eminem
yeah and uh then they rolled out a
purple lemonade but yeah yeah a few
months ago a few weeks ago yeah uh to as
a celebration of like inclusivity and
and diversity or something like that
they have a new purple m m so just stuff
like that I think we have like 80 close
to 80 prophecies the Black Mirror that
TV show Black Mirror the guy stopped
making them thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there